we got a great show tonight a lot of fun
stuff planned what does your sign say I
just I never point out something that
says you are my third crush what the
hell
why so specific now the whole night I'll
be thinking who are the other two David
Hasselhoff many people that make me feel
bad right was it other famous people oh
no I don't want to know I'm not gonna
ask okay tell me one David Bowie in
labyrinth though very specifically why
you are the queen of too much
information just say David Bowie dime
like I loved it in labyrinth
second one George Michael
[Applause]
No
bird crush I was that woman's third
Christ I know that was quite fascinating
what is your name my ass
what is that Shannon are you with your
boyfriend tonight that's your husband
dealer you aware that that that she had
three crushes before you she just held
up a sign that says she will leave you
for me that's gotta be the shittiest
thing I've ever seen every dude at the
anniversary pal horrifying dressing up
in labyrinth clothes that's terrible
at the anniversary I'll leave you from
whatever sir is it Oh congratulations
yeah I have been married for 20 years
you wouldn't mind 20 years I hadn't seen
her in three
[Laughter]
you